le journaliste sportif est placé en
garde à vue depuis ce matin 10h
journée du 20 novembre une hôtesse du
pain
ce jour-là elle se trouvait dans un
salon VIP avec le journaliste et selon
elle il lui reste toucher est la
poitrine elle en a parlé à sa supérieure
et suite à ce signalement le parquet de
Paris vous disiez a décidé le 20
novembre d'ouvrir une enquête pour
agression sexuelle cette agression
sexuelle et bien Pierre Ménès l'as
toujours nier lui déclare qu'il était
bien ce jour-là au Parc des Princes pour
la rencontre PSG Nantes mais qui ne sais
absolument rien passé
entendu depuis ce matin par les
enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
premier district donc en fait son avocat
voulait que Pierre Ménès entendu dans
cette affaire pour faire toute la
lumière toute la transparence la tête de
Pierre Ménès c'est qu'il n'y a rien et
effectivement dans un fossé carte pas
d'image pas de vidéo il y a pas de
document qui atteste il y a 6 personnes
maintenant donc un ancien policier qui
précise qu'il ne s'est rien passé ce
soir là ça fait au moins ça ça ça vous
avez une jeune femme pas porter plainte
mais dans la supérieur hiérarchique au
vu de ce qui s'est passé à signaler une
potentielle agression sexuelle donc il
est en garde à vue alors garde à vue ça
peut déboucher sur un non-lieu il peut
ressortir libre il est
le régime de la garde à vue n'est pas
lié à la demande d'être entendu ce sont
les instructions qui décide de vous
placer en garde à vue lui il aurait
voulu être entendu comme auditeur libre
ce qui s'est passé ça peut déboucher sur
plusieurs choses si vous voulez c'est un
peu plus
de
je ne prends parti pour personne ne veut
dire attention quand on est bien entendu
par la police c'est très différent c'est
ce que j'ai entendu quand on
considère qu'elle a déjà
parce que
après j'avais les accusations donc donc
donc ça y est il est il est tiré
d'affaire oui même si appelle donc oui
il est tiré d'affaire sur sa version il
n'a jamais fait varier d'un iota
c'est-à-dire que il a il est resté ferme
sur ses positions la plaignante elle
reste aussi belliqueuse elle veut faire
appel elle maintient que la procédure a
été d'un soleil à un avocat mais il y a
un non-lieu voilà